first of all
this is now being looked at by a
technical advisory group on virus
evolution so they can decide what status
to give it uh i want to say that in the
who there is absolute gratitude to
scientists in south africa for the speed
with which they've characterized this
virus and for their transparency and
openness in telling the rest of the
world about it
of course they're facing a backlash in
south africa because there are some uh
locally who are saying that by talking
about this that's led to immediate
actions against south africa and other
southern african countries that feel
like punishment and so where those of us
in the wh so feel really really torn
about this
yes it's good that the world knows about
the variant yes it's good that the
research is being done yes it's good
that we're answering the questions but
it is totally wrong
that there is uh vilification of the
south african scientists who've done the
work and i'd like to suggest that it's
really unfortunate that the immediate
reaction is to be to cancel
flights and to stop uh people from south
africa being able to travel yeah this is
interesting because the south african
health minister of course held a press
conference earlier here on sky news we
showed that he said that this was a
completely unjustified reaction from the
united kingdom europe also proposing to
suspend flights as well that's the
advisory there from ursula vonderline uh
do you think that it is unjustified some
might argue that the united kingdom is
actually learning from its past lessons
when we didn't shut down flights coming
in and out
so this is tricky number one
most of the evidence that we've had over
the years
tells us that it's really difficult to
keep viruses and bacteria
out of countries through border
restrictions
it just doesn't work
number two
what we've also learned
is that actually what you've really got
to do is to work on how the virus is
transmitted within your country right
now in the uk
there is very limited
official requirement for mask use at
least in england very little official
requirement for physical distancing and
very little official requirement for
hygiene
and yet
in wha we know that those are the most
effective ways of stopping this virus
from spreading
so it seems kind of odd that on the one
hand the uk is not following the
official guidance on what you do to
reduce covet spread but on the other
hand is saying we're going to move very
quickly to shut our borders when
certainly from the who side we have not
recommended that kind of action at all
so would you say that this is an
inefficient response and and not the
right one um given that the very basics
and to be honest you're not the first
expert i've spoken to on air over the
past few weeks who are saying the united
kingdom needs to go back to the basics
hands face space would you say that this
is an inefficient and
potentially
response that won't work
so i'm terribly careful not to make
remarks that appear to be critical of
any government but i am perfectly
prepared to encourage government action
where i think it's right
all over europe now the correct action
is that everybody should be wearing
well-fitted face masks at all times but
especially indoors and everybody should
be doing everything possible to avoid
breathing in air that is exhaled by
other people everyone should be
practicing really good hygiene
there should be good ventilation in
confined spaces and yes people should
get vaccinated if they're in the age
group that will benefit
we've got to do all these things this
virus is just unforgiving it is brutal
and it's coming back into europe with a
vengeance so please yes could we do
everything with regard to comments about
what's sorry do continue sorry
i just want to say that in general with
regard to decisions about flights from
southern africa
i just want to be very clear that as
soon as you start doing these kinds of
restrictions or travel bans
you're also having an impact on the
economy of countries that southern
african nations have been badly hit by
covid
they do not have
much room to be able to provide
extra support to people whose income
might be reduced because of unemployment
or other factors due to decisions taken
by other nations so just everybody when
you're going ahead and introducing these
kinds of unilateral travel restrictions
or whether it's for people from a
particular nation or for people who are
not vaccinated or whatever
please think of the human consequences
please speak to the people concerned
before you introduce the things because
we're all interdependent this pandemic
is everywhere and it's really
unfortunate when countries or groups of
countries act in a particular possibly
single-handed way without consulting
with others and i assume that also
applies to vaccines i'm afraid we're
going to have to leave it there david
nabarro i'm sure our viewers would love
to hear more from you thanks very much